Is, is drumming a young
man's game? I mean,
is it like athletics where as
you get older, drummer slow down?
I don't know.
I haven't,
I played just as wild as I did
back in the day and I will do,
you know 43 you look great. Oh
thank you. Don't look 43. Yeah.
Max Weinberg told me one time he was,
he watched me play and he was like at
a show or blink played and he's like,
I don't know how much longer
you can play like that.
Cause it was like real hard dude. He's
like, you're going to need back surgery.
You play like you have rabies smashing
the fucking drums. So knock on wood,
nothing has changed. And I've just, I
play exactly how I always have, you know,
um, I don't even want to think about a
day where I have to play any different.
Sure. It'll come. But do you get massages?
Yes. That'll help slot, right? Yeah.
Massages, Epson Salt, Bass. Um,
that's where the tank comes in
play. Man. That thing looks amazing.
The tank is all Epsom salts. Look at
you, dude. You don't fucking crazy
when you watch that. I watch
you play. And I would just go,
how the fuck and this
guy maintain this pace?
Cause everybody drums differently.
You know? I mean it's,
it's really interesting to watch
people's different, especially, uh,
my friend bill burr really got into
drumming and uh, you know, he's,
he's really into it and I like
watching them play and it's,
it's interesting to see someone take
something up and get better and take
lessons and learn it.
But the thing that really strikes me
is how many repetitions are involved.
Like as you're doing this,
like the,
the amount of times you're hitting
these drums is fucking insanity.
You gotta pace yourself. If it's
a two hour set, I know like, oh,
this is a verse of this song. I can kind
of, this is not a big, big part. You know,
you can kind of chill, but it's like a
round, you know, if you're doing around,
look up in the clock and you realize,
Oh wow, I still have two minutes left,
we'll pace yourself.
And you know what I mean?
That's kind of how I approached shows.
But,
but the goal is to train so much before
you even get on tour that you're not
even having to think about that.
You're just playing the show exactly
how you want to play. It's almost,
I imagine it's like that with fighting
where you envision what you want to do in
your head and you're in the shape and
you know the technique to execute.
You don't have to think about our goal,
like, oh, I can't do that. I'm not,
I didn't practice that enough.
I like to be able to just do whatever
I'm feeling and not, you know, be like,
well shit, I don't know how to do that
or I'm going to get tired if I do that.
I don't want that to happen.
You know? So that's the goal.
It's just being able to execute what
you have, the idea in your head. Well,
musicians have to have discipline
because you have to practice.
It's one of the things that makes you
guys so unique in the entertainment world.
It's like, I mean, I guess maybe actress
have to practice stand up comedians.
We only practice in front of an audience.
But you guys have to fucking practice so
you don't go on your show before you go
out. No, I write,
I write and I listened to
recordings of old sets,
but I don't like to sit in front of
a mirror and go, hey folks. Yeah,
I don't do that.
I don't know anybody because it feels
so weird when you go up to do what it
would feel were Hearst, right? Yeah.
That's the last thing you want.
You gotta be in the moment.
Same thing happens with it.
If you practice too much as a band and
then you go try to play those songs and
act like you're having fun,
that happens.
So I try to practice a lot on my own
and I'm not even practicing those songs.
Just kind of just drill, you know? Yeah.
But Sam Kinison used to have a joke
about the beach boys about a, they're,
they're going out there playing,
I wish they could all be California girls
again and like Jesus fucking Christ.
Like it becomes a job that you don't want,
that you want it to be fresh and exciting
and you want it to be something that
you're really in the moment
and really thinking about.
So I make up new shit on the spot too.
That's the best is I just make up new
fails or just try to reinvent the songs to
the point where even like Marco
look back at me and be like, wow,
you're going to do whatever.
Like that's the best, you know,
just kind of freaking it on the fry
and even to the crowd it's like Whoa,
that's cool.
You haven't heard it like that before.
So that's like after two or three months
of being on tour you do stuff like that.
Yeah.
When you get off tour,
do you consciously give yourself arrest?
No,
I'm busier at home than I am on tour
on tour. So lavish man like you have,
you have someone saying,
I mean,
you do have people kind of waiting on
you hand and foot somewhat, you know,
like a catering, you know,
ready if you want to eat or hey,
you got to go do an interview 30
minutes before you go onstage. Uh,
cars outside waiting for you after
the show, taking you to the hotel.
So that doesn't happen
at home and at home.
I do so many other things besides
play in the band. Like I, you know,
produce a bunch of rap artists. Um, I have
crossroads, I have clothing companies,
I have three kids. It's way
busier at home. Tours, tours,
a vacation. That's
interesting. Yeah, for me. Wow.
Cause I don't know how to say no either.
My Joe,
I have a lot of things I love that I love
doing, so I can't complain and be like,
Oh, I hate going to the steer. I
hate doing this. I love it all.
I just kind of love it all so much that
I have trouble saying no. Sometimes.